okay so Dragon Ball magic I mean Dragon
Ball DA has finally been announced and I
just need a moment to talk to you all
about that logo right there I canot get
over how obviously rushed this logo is
the plain lettering da with a white
stroke outline the clear eraser tool
stretch marks of the background it's all
just so funny and to be clear that sort
of rough brush stroke background is
something that can totally be done on
purpose but when looking at it as a
whole it's just so apparent that this
thing was made last second like they
even said in the revealed panel that
they finalized the series's name days
before the announcement in fact we
decided it like a few days ago so now
I'm just sat here imagining some poor
toi graphic design intern receiving an
email to the tune of uh hello we changed
the name please make a logo for the
announcement panel you have 24 hours uh
just know Anonymous toy graphic designer
I feel for you